welcome we have Eric here today so Eric
is a YC partner he was previously the
CEO and founder of pebble which went
through the YC batch and all the way
winter of 2011 a long time you're gonna
ban Eric so now we have the other
building on the other side but my Y C
batch was one of the last ones in this
small small building yeah you actually
it was called Alberta when you applied
yep and our product was called impulse
impulse yes we had a whole bunch of
complicated name how did you I mean
pebble is a great name how did you get
to a much better name yeah I think the
original names were found using a
thesaurus or some sort of like we just
like scan through a book for words that
were related to like alerting alert ah
that was how we got to it yeah
originally peple was much better name I
actually thought of it while lying on a
beach and it was like two years before
we actually made pebble I just like
wrote it down in Evernote on a list of
good names nice you never know you have
no idea when you're gonna use another
name so any good ones just written down
so today I want to spend a little time
talking about hardware startups giving
you ran one especially one that was one
of the larger hardware starts in the
past few years but then spend a bulk of
the time talking about hard tech because
you spend a lot of time working with our
tech or here at YC and there are a lot
of unknown still out there and we
obviously want to fund more of those
couldn't startups so starting with
pebble so can you take us through like a
quick story up you know when you came to
I see how big were you what did you
doing well I see like that's actually a
common question of what hard for
startups actually do what I see in three
months so we applied to YC started the
company in 2008 started working on it
while I was still a student at Waterloo
kept working that through 2010 we hadn't
actually shipped or we were we were just
starting to ship the product to first
customers this is before couple back
into in mid-2010 and
I've been on Hacker News forever but I
never really understood what Y
Combinator was I just thought it was
like the domain name for Agri news and
one day someone said hey you should
check out like YC and so just on a whim
we applied the video we recorded if I
look back at it was during Oktoberfest
in Kitchener Waterloo where I was living
and we were wearing like Oktoberfest
Macedon video we applied for some crazy
reason Paul Graham Jessica and the gang
decided to accept us even though I think
we were the third hardware company that
got through
we started YC in 2011 in the winter and
the company the stage of the company was
we had shipped maybe take two or three
hundred of our very first watch the
watch that that was called impulse that
worked with blackberry smartphones and
we had some early customers we were
getting money but we hadn't we were hit
we were earning some money hadn't raised
much I think I borrowed fifteen thousand
bucks from my parents got some
government grants in Canada which was
quite easy but we hadn't raised any
money from investors YC was the first
first investor so $15,000 let you
manufacturers at the first one hundred
units I we ended up making them had one
by one actually so the first watches for
this first watch they were manufactured
we bought the circuit boards from China
we had the metal the kind of metal
casing of the watch made at a small
metal shop a guy had a CNC a five axis
CNC printer or a mill and he actually
just like he read about us in the school
newspaper or something like that and
offered to like be our first shop for
making the actual metal cases so the
middle case would get made just to write
like couple blocks away you get the
circuit boards shipped in from China we
also made the plastic watch straps in
China and then we would do the final
assembly one by one in the garage and I
think that early process of making
everything one by one was perfect for us
because we screwed up everything you
could possibly screw up the first ten
watches we had weight
a lot of problems but we had problem
with RF we couldn't get the signal out
of the watch because it's like a Faraday
cage sitting on your wrist and so we
said well maybe let's change the metal
back for a plastic back and so we had a
whole bunch of laser-cut acrylic you
know she got a plastic cut to the same
size as the back of the watch and we
kind of jammed it in and then we shipped
the first ten of them out by FedEx and
on something like seven out of the ten
the electronics just exploded at the
back of the plastic and like people
would show us pictures of like this
watch the vigeous Bob with like the guts
just everywhere and so we adjusted the
thing we started putting like up like a
piece of foam rubber inside the watch so
when we shipped it the the backswing
explode but it was a really good thing
that we were making them one by one or
else we could have potentially made like
hundreds with that same problem right at
the beginning and had lost you know
so we I think we iterated really really
quickly and we screwed up it was only a
maximum of like a pretty small screw-up
and how many units were you that you
sold before you actually went through
the entire manufacturing process we
continued to manufacture hand by hand
one by one by hand up until around 700
800 units
so even when so one of the things that
people ask about YC is like well what
happens if I have like have to move my
business to to Mountain View you know
it's gonna interrupt my production
process or whatever so what we did was I
hired a couple high school students and
I asked one of my friends who I went to
school with who was doing his master's
back at Waterloo just kind of like
manage and run the the production thing
and they would ship him down here and we
would finish it in our house that we
were all living at and so I think the
trick there was like we didn't we didn't
let the fact that we had to be here in
Mountain View interrupt our actual like
sales process and so after YC pebble
obviously took off and lots of great
things happen more of it I mean he went
through lots of ups and downs it's a
year after YC it wasn't like immediately
after took a long time yeah so what was
the hard
part maybe out of your old journey with
pebble looking back I think it's
different because you know seeing it
forward it actually took us a long time
to get from the initial idea to any sort
of like real product market fit it was
five years so we started the company in
2008 built the initial prototype late
2008 2009 since start shipping until
2010 and that was for our first watch
and then we you know had a lesson had a
lot of lessons learned from that first
production run and then we redesigned
and created what would become pebble in
2012 so that's five years and the
hardest thing like I would say we work
with a lot of founders and the hardest
question that I think I ever get as
someone who helps startups is like how
do I know that what I'm working on is
the right thing to work on how do I know
that this little pivot that I could do
is not the right one like maybe I should
try that and there's no answer to this
it is the hardest problem and so I you
know thinking back I think it was
probably very misguided in that I just
had faith and I just never gave up even
though now thinking back it's insane
doing something for five years
like what's the definition of insanity
doing the same thing and hoping for
different results like I was basically
doing that for five years like we were
just I guess we didn't know what we
didn't know like we were very naive and
we had a very small amount of money and
we didn't know that you're not supposed
to make consumer hardware products on a
budget of $40,000 like most electronics
that you use are made with budgets of
millions of dollars I mean but now that
you've done it or you did do it do you
think it's possible now it's todya
hotspur who know what I'm saying is I
think like the hardest part that we had
to go through was not letting other
people get us down and kind of like
maintaining that naive it say one of the
things that I really love about like
that phase at startup was people
couldn't really convince us that what we
were doing was wrong because no one had
really done it before and if people said
like oh you know
you should you know and you should look
at raising more money or something like
that me did really have the resources to
do that like we were very we were very
constrained and naive team and so he had
to figure it out and I think some of the
ways that I could screw it up was
actually the ways that I did screw it up
was right after YC we raised a bit of
money about two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars including this this
kind of large check that we got from one
investor and I took all that money and
invested in inventory because I thought
at the time the biggest constraint on us
growing was we didn't have a reliable
like we didn't have a large amount of
imagery we were making them by hand and
so we only had like 10 or 50 a week and
I was under the mistaken impression that
if we could start selling it in real
time rather than saying we'll do a
pre-order in celle - in a couple weeks
that our sales would have taken off more
because then we tried this we
manufacture we instead of making them by
hand you know in our garage we went to a
small contract manufacturer in San Jose
and manufactured 3,000 at once and spend
all of our money on that and you know
you know I'll see that the story is
going it takes longer than you expect to
bring up a new manufacturer so it took
six months or eight months instead of
three months it cost more than we
expected so the BOM cost Road rose and
then by the time we actually manufacture
them that eight months rolled around our
email list of potential customers had
kind of dried up everyone had switched
from blackberry to using iPhones and
then we were stuck with a whole bunch of
inventory so that yeah that was a really
that was a really rough yeah difficult
part yeah it's often not always but in
many cases people get really creative
when they don't have much money it may
have to get really scrappy and then when
they raise a ton of money they forget
how to do that later
we raised a bunch of money and then
started hiring it and this is a big
problem even mostly the successful
companies run into and so I think the
moral of the story for me at least how I
think about you know
that I work on is like that that
frugality is vital to me not everyone
has the same and not every industry is
exactly the same if you crazy industries
right now which are kind of by
definition the opposite approval I'm
thinking of like the scooter scooter
sure where it's a matter of like raising
as much money and it's physically
possible but for the vast majority of
people like staying frugal is what
actually like yeah if you don't have
Network like obvious network effects our
first mover advantage then usually you
should get on the other path so pebble
is known as one of the most you dip them
one of the most successful crowdfunding
campaigns on Kickstarter and so a lot of
people view crowdfunding is a way in
lieu of fundraising to do that route so
I think there are a lot of questions on
what is the right time to do it
especially like at what point do I need
a you know a product that is real and it
works
do I need to align that with the
crowdfunding campaign and so forth so
what's your advice on that I have a
after having gone through a couple of
these cycles here's my advice
I think crowdfunding can be useful for
two specific points I mean mainly useful
for two specific points in a startups
like you could use crowdfunding at the
very early stage when you have an idea
on the back of a napkin maybe a render
or two to raise twenty five fifty
thousand dollars that can help you get
to a working prototype this is for
people who are software engineers and
are experimenting or want to work with
hardware this is for hardware engineers
who have zero money and they just want
to like do they just want to prove that
some people want their product so I want
to be very specific like this is it this
is an intention play it's not trying to
be to build like a multi-million dollar
campaign with like super fancy CGI
graphics and overproduced videos like
I'm talking about people honestly saying
I just need a little bit of money to get
this idea off the ground and I think
there's an opportunity to use crowd
right there it can be as simple as just
emailing a bunch of your friends and
saying hey do you want to just want one
of these this is like the best test that
you could that you can have for early
product market fit is do your friends
and family actually want to pay you
money for what you're making or do le
customer to actually want to prepay for
what you're making it's not perfect
because you know they may want to try it
first or something like that but if you
are making something that people really
want they're basically throwing their
money at you so that's it that's an
opportunity for kind of this early
crowdfunding I really encourage people
to not try to do the marketing blow out
campaign at the start for two reasons
one is just looking back most of those
campaigns even if they do succeed at
raising money usually fail to produce
and actually ship their product and I
think the reason why is going through
this cycle of having to make something
and ship it to customers is really
educational and you also learn what
people like about your product or what
they don't like as quickly it's like you
reduce the amount of time between you
having the idea and you're getting
validation of do people actually want
this idea so that's the first I think
opportunity for crowdfunding I think
there's actually another opportunity
using it more as like a marketing and
sales channel which I think more of what
we did where we had already made most
people don't know this but when we
launched our Kickstarter campaign we had
already made and sold around 1500 of our
first watch and so we had gone through
like all the pain and the cycle of
building that and we had a really good
idea of what pebble should look like
because we had feedback from about 1,500
individuals who were like super eager
early adopters very open with their
feedback and we tune and tweak the
product so I think there's kind of like
two separate crowdfunding opportunities
and like a consumer products life cycle
I think too often people blend them
together or they don't know which path
they're on and so they kind of screwed
it up they they there's actually a
couple other platforms for this early
crowdfunding there's you know
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo and that kind
of thing but there's also tindy there's
crowd supply there's like hackaday
forums it's a lot of like really niche
areas where you could you go to a
discord server and say
like you don't have to use the
Kickstarter platforms for that early
phase do you suggest having like a date
in which you know I can promise you I
can actually deliver this because if I'm
using Kickstarter with the first with
you know the first route maybe I don't
know that I can deliver it within six
months is there's like a certain time
period in which I know I can deliver
then I do that and if you're not like I
would I would encourage like if you're
not confident in your ability to ship it
then don't use one of these like
crowdfunding campaign platforms where
it's very centric like shipping centric
there's other options and again like I
really do encourage going through that
first cycle to find out things like how
long does it take me to make things do I
have all the skills on my team or do I
actually have to find you know people
potentially in the community to help
contribute software or other other
skills to the team again like too many
people I see like they skip that step
and they try to go directly to like the
high-powered marketing campaign and it's
just it's just such a sad time most of
the time yeah and sometimes there's on
Kickstarter kind of early adopters yeah
but there's a group before now exactly I
think for your given industry and for
your given product category you should
be able to find it like sometimes it's
as simple as going on like a subreddit
like we've had some great companies come
through YC and they do their initial
sales just by earning credibility in a
Facebook group or they earn credibility
in a reddit you know group or discord
like there's a ton of customers there so
when you talked about pep Laura Lee
talked about hiring people and
outsourcing things what's the right call
in terms of outsourcing the various
components so this is a really hard
question for hard tech companies because
more often than not the skill sets that
you'll need to build to build your
products are actually quite varied you
may need a mechanical engineer an
electrical engineer a computer engineer
some you know
production people ops people and you
don't necessarily need 100% of that
person all the time you need like 15% or
20% for three weeks and then you're back
to not needing an electrical engineer so
the best the best way to solve this is
to have really flexible technical people
on your team where you guys can just
kind of incorporate everything and just
do it yourself because those teams move
so much faster than teams that require
an external kind of process some of the
most painful moments of my early career
were not having full-time co-founders
and having to work with contractors or
consultants who honestly like you can't
pay someone enough to care I mean
firstly because you probably don't have
that much money but also because people
who are working on contract they're just
set up to not have the same motivations
than the same alignments that someone
who's working 24/7 trying to get their
fledgling startup off the ground has you
run into time commitments I just had got
an email the other day for my founder
who's like yeah our intern went back to
school and he was developing a large
portion of our company and so yeah so
like I actually opted for in the early
days and pretty much all days trust and
dependability and and and kind of
smartness over very specific deep domain
specific knowledge in who I'm looking to
hire so last question on hardware
specifically there's this common saying
or adage what do you want to call it
like hardware you can't just build
Hardware you have to have a software
component so that just scales you can
have like a subscription service on top
of it instead of just the one off type
purchase how much do you believe in that
or what do you think about people who
say that all the time so I've been I've
been working on I've been doing a bit of
research into this category it's really
got me interested right after pebble
because that was some feedback that we
often got could you launch a
subscription service could you have some
sort of payment subscription and you've
heard of product market fit right you
know the idea that customers really you
know in a particular market are going
after your product I actually think
there's something called like business
model company fit where you could have
the best product in the world you could
actually have product market fit but if
you have the wrong business model you're
not gonna be able to fund and you know
grow your company over the long term so
it's kind of like an advanced thing but
you don't need to worry about this if
you'll have product market fit because
you know how product market fit you know
you don't have a company but we ran into
a problem pretty soon after we hit
product market fit of misunderstanding
what was the what was the business model
that was going to drive this company and
I think there's actually like seven or
eight or nine different business models
that are useful that that are kind of
like lanes that hardware companies or
heart tech companies can can use I've
been working on the kind of just kind of
researching and putting companies into
different categories and you have the
subscription companies like the nests
and the or the dropcam's of the world
that are selling you know ring healthy
three to ten dollar subscriptions per
month but then you see other companies
that try to do something similar and it
just does not work and I think that's
because so in our case we didn't
struggle I think with subscriptions we
experimented with it it wasn't really
going to work for us but the way that we
screwed it up was we didn't understand
that we were in hits driven market hits
driven being you come up with a consumer
product hopefully it's a hit it hits
that product market fit and people start
pulling it out of your hands similar to
a game company we didn't realize that we
had to be super frugal super kind of low
budget as we developed the new products
and kind of tried to engineer another
hit our first product was certainly a
hit I don't think we ever reached escape
velocity to a hit with any of our later
products and I think if we had built a
more frugal organization if we were able
to build products cheaper and then
launch them and test to see if they were
successful and
they were successful scale it up etc I
think we might have had a slightly
different outcome and it kind of goes
back to like there are these different
models for hardware companies and you
need to like you need to you need to
make sure that you're on the right but
you have to question yourself and you're
like should we really be on a
subscription model is this really what
customers are gonna want what they want
to spend five dollars ten dollars a
month and you can't force it and if you
force it like I think we tried to do you
you might add extra problems like on top
of just building great products for your
customers
so pivoting a little bit too hard tech
so we've funded lots of cool hard tech
companies lately quantum computing
self-driving cars pretty printing entire
homes so for agriculture technology yeah
nuclear fission nuclear fusion aerospace
space space yes Rockets satellites and
rockets so I mean we can calibrate the
conversation a little bit how do you
define hard tech deep tech what does
that really involve for me I think what
what I'm excited about you know in
harder technology spaces is that is the
in the in the software world the
iteration cycles are quite short
you can push code to your to your repo
and have it go live within seconds and
so you can rapidly iterate on your
product and get feedback from your
customers I think hard tech companies
can't they don't have this same rapid
iteration cycle they either have
hardware in the mix which kind of is not
at that same speed yet though it is it
is dramatically decreasing the amount of
time that each iteration cycle takes or
you might have some sort of fundamental
technology that you're working on that
needs to be developed in order to unlock
a new business model or new use case or
you might be regulatory regulatory
constrained either in the medical device
space drone space transportation space
software on car space these are all like
there's external processes that you
can't control that affect your iteration
cycle time so say this crazy idea
something to do with rockets or
something insane it's to most people
normal to me of course rocket scientist
and I have no money what away what do we
even start what do I do it doesn't cost
that much money to get started these
days you can do something like startup
school where they give you free money to
invest in like if you're working on AR
machine learning you can use that to get
compute credits well maybe a better
question is what is an MVP for most of
these yeah Carter Tech so for medical
devices
I think the MVP is successfully
peer-reviewed science that supports what
you're working on that that there's not
that there's some sort of opportunity
here and a kind of understanding of what
your path to clearance is those are in
my opinion I think the best companies
because they're the ones who have shown
that they understand which business
model they're in and they know what's
going to take what's gonna be taken of
them to get to kind of sales but they
don't necessarily have to be like too
far along that path I think at that
stage investors start to get excited
when they see the mating of science
Senna and a use case we've had a bunch
of companies that are working on rockets
and satellites and propulsion and that
kind of thing
for those cases it's usually some sort
of subset scale representation of what
you're working on and customers so in
all cases even if you're working on
regulatory constrained products having
customers either contributing money to
you through early contracts or or
further along on the kind of pilot track
the better I think oftentimes engineers
we love to build things we don't as much
love to sell them and so what I look for
in early-stage companies is are the
founders technically competent and do
they understand that they're gonna have
to kind of perverse themselves become
salespeople or not what do you find by
demo day when they're in front of lots
of investors what is it that you
encourage them to accomplish by then it
sounds like there's two passers the
if you can do sales there's no
regulatory issues to doing sales you
should have some paid contracts ll eyes
maybe and then also a technical
validation like proof that you can
actually built this yeah and I think too
often people convolve these and they say
I don't want to do sales until I have
something that I can show to them that's
just not true
most customers if you explain that they
have a problem and you have a way to
solve it they'll get excited and if
they're not excited it's probably a sign
that they don't really have a problem
that they want to solve and so
oftentimes we get companies that come in
at the beginning YC and they say well we
want to spend the first two months you
know working on improving the prototype
and getting it to the point where we're
proud of it and then we'll do sales in
the last month and you know we kind of
flip that around like do the sales hit
the pavement like talk to customers and
you'll actually build a better first
product for them than if you just built
it first and showed it it also gives you
confidence that you're going down the
right track someone said it's hard like
we had a company in the last batch that
had been working for two years on
building a prototype they were
commercializing some technology that
they worked on in a university and it
had a hardware component and I remember
seeing I think was their third
application second or third application
to YC and they had kind of similar
videos of them doing the demo with their
technology and we you know we liked
their commitment like they had been
coming back and the technology was
getting better and they were just
starting to talk to customers and we
said let's give him a shot and so we
brought him in for an interview accepted
them in and then basically the first
week we took him aside and just said you
need to start selling you need to get
people like excited and interested and
it was almost like a 180 for them
because they thought that we were going
to say you should work on technology and
get to the point where you have like
working units widgets that you can sell
and we said no like start going and
talking to customers and they it took a
little while for them to get up to speed
they you know it's a it's like
exercising your new muscle especially
for engineers and within
span of two months they went through
several rollercoasters of like having
zero leads to having a whole bunch of
leads to having them all collapse and no
one's signing and then like six or seven
weeks into YC they they they sense no
and they were like we got our first we
got our first contract and then they got
their second contract they got their
third and then like my demo day they had
already had already like line on four or
five million dollars in sales and that
all happened in the span of three months
because they've kind of you know stopped
working necessarily on just building
their technology they were still working
like they had a three or four person
team so they hey they were able to split
it up but the focus that number one goal
became how do we get sales so say I mean
you do a lot of trips where you go to
schools specifically you talk to
scientists and engineers many and peach
tea programs because what is what is
your advice to them to make the jump
which they consider a lot of them are
thinking about commercializing it but
maybe they think I don't know what they
think actually but but what is your I
guess went like one-two punch on that
having started my company in a kind of
university town versus somewhere here
like Silicon Valley I felt very kind of
protected there were a lot of government
grants I was able to raise non dilute of
funding and Plus that is we were able to
use that funding to work on the project
but the downside was there was no
pressure to have some sort of product
that customers would pay money for it
wasn't really in the DNA of the startup
kind of ecosystem that I was in most
people were just entranced with working
on their startup and not necessarily
getting to that next stage of building
kind of a profitable longer-term Corp
and I think that that sometimes affects
people who are in universities even more
because the the the default is raising
money through grants and working on
longer-term projects whereas the special
case is like spinning out a company and
actually like trying to get customers to
buy it and I think what I would
encourage is like try getting out of
your comfort zone
just as an experience like or experiment
don't don't say that you have to like
dive in headfirst with no parachute but
if you're working on some sort of
technology that you think could have
some sort of positive business impact
like get out of the lab go to some
conferences talk to people not not
educational conferences like corporate
you know sales conferences start talking
to customers and see what people think
and like that's that's the start and
hopefully I mean if you're if you're
lucky and things are in the right spot
again customers will be like where's
this been all my life like this is this
is amazing this is exactly what we've
been dreaming of I can't believe it
finally came out of the lab and that
should be the momentum that just like
pulls you pulls you along but you have
to get out to please try it so so you
get to the point where you feel
confident you have like some amount of
interest in your product but to actually
build it you can eat lots and lots and
lots of money what do you need to show
to investors so the best the best
companies in my opinion are the ones
that don't require a ton of money to
work on or at least to get to some sort
of MV MVP stage kind of like with all
advice that once he gives it's usually
applicable to 90% of the companies and
there's always 5% on either side that
are in a special case but even some of
the best hard tech companies I've seen
they don't have like a binary outcome
where they need someone to insert a
hundred million dollars and that's the
only thing that can develop the product
like take I mean I don't know anything
about these companies in other than kind
of press reports but take kind of magic
leap versus oculus right magic leap
raised lots of money and spent 11 years
working on a product versus oculus which
raised two million dollars on
Kickstarter shipped a you know early
development development kit that was not
amazing but they iterated and they got
through and now the oculus
[Music]
the new one that's like 400 bucks
doesn't new computer like it's it's
exactly yea the quest like that's
exactly what people are dreaming of now
and they're gonna have it within six
months and they had to go through like
six seven years of like painful
iteration but they did it and yeah so
last question then we'll take audience
questions
what's an idea just so curious what's an
idea that sounded so crazy to you when
you heard about it but then when you met
the founder and they stepped through
everything or like oh that's not so
crazy this is totally possible
relativity space so that was company
that went through YC for three years ago
not very long they wanted to build 3d
printed rockets their thesis was it's
not actually rocket assembly that cost a
lot of money it's the testing phase of
integration or if you have hundreds of
different systems that have to work
perfectly with each other when you
assemble and build the final rocket you
have to test everything select a
different path than like SpaceX which is
going for the reasonably T thing so
their their thesis was if we can 3d
print the entire rocket from the tip of
the exhaust to the motor to everything
in like one piece the integration time
is zero because you just print it so
they're working on this and it was just
an idea I think they did a hot fire
during YC I think they were working on
it I don't know exactly how long they've
been working on it for but yeah that's
pretty crazy idea and to come through YC
especially to pitch to investors that
probably were not you know all space
investors must have taken some guts but
they did it they showed off their first
three printed rocket they raised early
funding off of that they started work on
their larger products and raised a whole
bunch more money I think they just
raised their P or C last year they also
they worked at previously at SpaceX
origin but they didn't have many years
of experience so it was
actually craziness ends also they were
extremely young and for this kind of
thing - yeah thing in this and people
people believed in their in their vision
they demonstrated enough I think of what
they were working on and I think it was
actually interesting so I think they I
don't want to say too much in case I'm
wrong but I think they were working on
the printer first and they were looking
for an application for this massive
metal 3d printed they'd built and they
found space as the I mean it was their
background and their passion so I think
that's the one that they took it in the
direction that they took it in I see
this a lot with people who are working
on really cool kind of fundamental
technology
I think PG actually had a pretty good
tweet about this couple weeks ago he
said like if you're in a situation where
you're building something that's like
mind-blowing ly cool and revolutionary
but you're finding that customers don't
want to buy it pivot your companies so
you're actually doing what your
customers would have done and just use
your pioneering technology to do what
they do faster better or cheaper and
sell to their customers and that's kind
of I think what relativity did is they
were building this new 3d printer and
they realized that we could just build
rockets with this technology and we will
be better than everyone else who's
building rockets in that space cool so
questions first so the question was how
do you get your first customers how do
you get one through 50 I talked about
this a little bit earlier some of the
best ways is to kind of infiltrate the
community of people who want who you
think will watch your product there are
an unlimited place unlimited set of
places on the internet where people talk
about products and they talk about
services they can range from you know
where the whatsapp guy posted his app
first in back in 2009 now he posted it
on flyer talk for
which is like a whole bunch of like
geeky business people who fly a lot and
that's where you posted it and like
think about that as your first as the
first kind of user group for whatsapp
it's perfect right
it's travelers who want to talk to
people all around the world who are
tired of paying for overpriced like SMS
bills and it's 2009 so people are just
starting to get like smartphones and
that kind of thing perfect like you
couldn't have planned it better if you
tried and so the best companies are the
ones that just kind of get out there for
us we got a lot of press in the early
days by talking to bloggers so I like
formed personal relationships with all
of the BlackBerry bloggers at the time
if anyone remembers CrackBerry
CrackBerry Kevin yeah and so I would
like fly out to conferences on like
their cheap red eyes and just like
instead of buying tickets to the
conference I think we were just kind of
like sneak around and get into the print
like once at CES back in 2009 we just
just walked into and gadgets trailer
like Engadget had this big trailer where
all their reporters were working and we
didn't know anyone so we just walked in
and then just started like pitching to
people and ended up getting us through
this like a picture of my wrist with a
broken watch it didn't even work at the
time but it's like so-and-so is working
on a SmartWatch and that drove a ton of
traffic in the early days was just kind
of people's self identifying as this was
something that that I wanted yeah takes
a lot of hustle yeah things are much
easier so the question is like we're a
bunch of software engineers we have an
idea that had includes software and
hardware how do we get started on the
hardware well the good news is that it's
easier than ever I wrote I wrote a blog
post that was on TechCrunch a couple
months ago about how software engineers
can kind of get started on this and the
recipe is pretty simple find an
off-the-shelf product that kind of
what you want to do that's kind of like
halfway there that you can actually just
buy off Amazon or Alibaba or something
because the amount of like the amount of
time and money and tears that you'll
save just by buying a product that's
halfway to what you want to build will
will do a couple things one is it will
get you within two to three days or
however long shipping takes an actual
physical representation of what you
think you want to build and you will
begin to use it hopefully to solve the
problem that you want to solve and you
will learn like maybe I'm completely
wrong and this often happens like the
best intention product when you actually
build it might not actually solve the
problem that you want to solve so
getting halfway there for like two
hundred bucks or three hundred bucks
plus shipping it's just so much better
than weeks and months of prototyping
just to get to the same kind of level
the next step after this is to take the
50% their product or 75% their product
and hack it to do what you think is
better either adding a little bit of
technology onto it adding your software
stack modifying it can be as simple as
like repurposing the same technology and
like it's changing that changing the
setup a good example of this would be
kind of a scooter companies they took
Xiaomi scooters you know nine bought
scooters and they just glued on cell
modems that's it that that's how scooter
sharing starts like cell modems and GPS
plus scooter he didn't build this
scooter themselves they bought it off
Alibaba and they bought the modems from
some company that was making modems so
that's kind of the prototype I think for
the next generation of consumer hardware
as well as enterprise hardware we had a
company two batches ago that builds
cameras for neighborhoods neighborhood
security and they used a Raspberry Pi in
a PI cam and a 3d printed case and they
sold those for like hundreds of
thousands of dollars the hardware cost
you know very small amount of money and
they're just solving a real problem for
end customers and people are paying them
in exchange for that so yeah it's it's
even easier than ever you can find
people in Alibaba you can meet factories
over reach at just
don't try to build it all yourself don't
hire like an industrial design firm to
build you some new design don't hire
like an engineering firm that promises
to do a custom design for you because
that'll cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars and it probably will be the
wrong product versus spending 300 bucks
find something meeting the factory that
makes that current product and asking
them to kind of make the changes that
you want to make it depends so the
question is should you move should you
move closer to changing or factories
when you are pre product market fit if
your free product market fit and you
have a product that you're iterating on
like figure out a way to reduce the
iteration cycles so that you get more
chances to dazzle customers and to find
you know that product market fit so you
could solve that two ways if you think
that moving to the factories would
be--if will enable you to do faster
iteration and you already have kind of
sales channels set up that's cool if not
and you don't really have that many
customers then move closer to your
customers so that you know the iteration
can be done in software maybe not
hardware and you're just like spending
every minute in front of your customers
so we have a couple companies that did
that in the last batch and they were
using drones to solve very specific
business process problems and they
basically just moved to where those
businesses are took up like a motel a
crappy motel room and turn that motel
room into a like a drone factory where
they were making and modifying their
drone and that in that case you know was
probably recall for them protection IP
protection trademark protection is that
kind of what you're interested so yeah
patents that kind of thing so this
question I think kind of touches on how
do you build a moat for your company how
do you make sure that once you figure
out a beautiful product figure out who
to sell it to that some other dude
doesn't come along and just steal your
idea so there's a couple ways that you
can solve this
the best ways in my opinion are
companies that have some sort of innate
moat where it's either Network effect
where the more people that use your
product the better it is for everyone or
some sort of data a lot data lock-in
where you use the product you generate
data the davida happens to be within one
ecosystem someone who builds a competing
piece of hardware can't get that data
easily those are the two best what do
you think about that I think those are
good I also think patent previously used
to be very hard to get but now there's
like we have a company called cognition
IP I would just use them and you pay
them some amount of money they use
software to help you file so the the
problem with patents is that they're not
like if you're thinking about this
problem specifically how do we block
other people from copying our idea
they're actually really difficult tools
to use versus those other two things
that I described that are actually like
you control all the levers if you can
build a product that has built-in
network effect or built-in data's you
know things you control that you don't
have to rely on lawyers you don't have
to rely on the government you'll have to
rely on the courts to enforce your
domain dominance but if you were if you
rely on patents or that kind of thing
you're basically saying I I I'm putting
this money down as an investment but I'm
gonna have to invest a lot more money
later in order to use unlock that first
investment so it's very rare that
startups build a successful moat using
patents this happens much more in like
biotech so yes yeah I agree with that I
think the I think building really great
product is really just the only way to
really build the moat I mean again for
like 5% of companies there might be some
sort of patent strategy be a 95 percent
it's it's great products yeah I think if
it's also easy to build people just copy
it even if you get that and so it
doesn't really no that's the thing you
need money to enforce the patents you
need time to enforce it and if your
companies dead it's hard to enforce
patents
[Music]
marginal markets are great so the
question was what happens if I'm
building a hard tech problem longer-term
trying to solve a longer-term problem
that first problem that I'm solving what
if it looks too small honestly the best
investors will want to see a small
market because a small market at the
beginning means you can identify who's
in that market very cheaply versus
having to boil the ocean saying well
there's like two percent of all people
in the world who are interested versus
like eighty percent of this one group so
it's cheaper and easier for you to find
those customers the second thing is that
small group of people will tell you
quicker whether you have a good product
or not because they know what the they
know that they have a problem and you're
telling them hey buy this thing solve
your problem they can use it in big yeah
that solves it it's good yeah problem
solved they'll give you feedback whereas
if you're trying to again target like a
really large group with a vague product
idea it's gonna be harder to know
whether that person just was interested
that week maybe didn't have enough money
you know there's there's more reasons
than you had a bad product if it's a
really vague in large large market yeah
just add on to that I think starting
small is good but also having a road map
to how it builds into something big as
good as well for investors specifically
and for yourself as well to know like
keep keep motivated
feminine so in my company by chance we
just like to it's an electronic
treatment for reducing sweating and we
we are so happy that people are so this
cuz this questions related to like do I
do I pick a recurring business model
subscription business model hardware is
a service or do I just sell the product
so this kind of goes back to what I was
talking about before which is making
sure that you have the right you you're
pretty sure that you're in the right
business model track for your company so
there are a lot of these different
tracks they're not just hardware's a
service not just consumer there's hybrid
models there's insurance models there's
you know advertising driven models
there's a ton of different ways that you
could look at it so it's not just one or
the other
here's what I would say on the
enterprise side you need to figure out
how much money you will save your
customer or how much more money they
will make and price your product
accordingly like your product price to
them will be less than either how much
they're saving or how much more they're
making and you should try to price it as
high as possible to still let them have
some savings but you should you know
right right
rightfully so earn some of the profit
from that innovation that you have
sometimes that may be a hardware as a
service model it might be upfront and it
really depends on kind of your customer
at that point so it's really hard for
anyone to try to give advice on that in
that front and it's much more around
like talking to customers experimenting
you could do price experiments know most
companies are so small that every time
like a new person hears sorry every time
they do PR new people who've never heard
about it will hear about it for the
first time and they won't know what the
last price was so you can afford to like
do that kind of experimentation
especially at the beginning of your
company
yeah how do you do hiring especially
when you're scaling hiring is a mode
that the companies in and it's a very
distracting mode so I think like the
mission of an early stage startup is to
get the product market fit and it's
definitely not to like hire a team no
one gets points for hiring a team or you
get a very small number of points for
hiring an amazing team you get a lot
more points for finding a product that
has proper market fit so hiring in
general is really like a touchy subject
these there's no one size
one-size-fits-all there some general
advice that I have is what I mentioned
before which is higher for trust and
higher for reliability over hiring for
specific domain knowledge this has
really benefited me because right after
we kind of hit on Kickstarter we were
only two people at the company two
full-time people and two interns and so
we had like nobody and all of a sudden
we needed to hire people and we could
have spent you know three to six months
hiring a 30 person team and won all
these different you know people that we
would need hire expert experts that have
done it before we could've spent time
doing that we would have delayed our
initial production by probably three to
six months however long it would have
taken to hire that team so what I did
instead was I just phoned up like some
of my best friends from University who
had been tangentially involved in the
project and said you need to quit your
job and just fly here and I think all of
them we just hired seven people within
three or four days like that and that
worked because we had that momentum and
we had found product market fit and so
they were like that's cool I want to be
part of this rocket ship I want to take
off but we didn't have to do like three
to six months worth of hiring we did
three to six days with the hiring
and I knew them I trusted them they were
instantly part of a team because it was
just like we were working on another
school project again it seems like the
best source pool is either people you
met in college or from somewhere else
you've had yeah yeah like Pete like too
often people overlook like some of they
worked at a job with two three years ago
one of the coolest psych hacks that you
can do is just look through them
manually slowly look through your
Facebook or LinkedIn and just look at
every person's name and think is this
person cool and technical and just go
through that list and you'll probably
find a co-founder you'll probably find a
first employee like some long-lost
friend from high school that's actually
like a super cool developer you could
hire her and just bring her onto the
team like there's the second step people
miss then is actually asking that person
and giving a real offer there's always a
people do this ambiguous dance of like I
don't want you to say no to me and
that's so I'm not gonna really ask you
and so there's there's a there's a good
book called the hard thing about hard
things by Ben Horowitz and he talks a
lot about like working with friends and
the difficulties and benefits of working
with friends so I read that book used to
end up hiring or working with a bunch of
your friends all right
[Music]
is there a lick question was for some
projects problems they can be solved
exclusively by software how do you know
when to involve hardware in it and when
in doubt take all the hardware out does
it solve the problem that's the best
place to start that's why I was kind of
saying like how could you just buy
something off the shelf and use it
because you may need some hardware you
maybe be camera you may need a
microphone you may need a compute
platform just buy a Raspberry Pi and
plunk USB devices into it like don't you
don't need to build anything these days
some people think like but it's not
going to be the right form factor or
it's not going to you know do the exact
right thing as what I think our
customers need just try just reject
build something hack something together
and see if it at least
almost solves the problem because like I
was saying more often than not that
initial test will prove that either you
have a really good problem that really
needs to be solved or nobody really has
that problem and you don't need to now
spend three months working on custom
hardware to mr. because the whole user
experience make difference so actually
we are creating the whole graphic it's
not least 182 people but it's really the
product is great but middle so it's
really bad so what is the best way to
pass way so the question was we really
complex product an AI psychotherapist or
therapist that can that can help people
how do we demo that or how do we convey
that product to people I would hazard a
guess that you know it's kind of a
similar question to last one it's like
are there ways that we can do this in
software rather than hardware so if I
were working on a project like that I
might start by actually creating the
assistant as an app first or maybe like
a 3d you know unity character that
approximates it that gets similar close
to what you want to do or use an
off-the-shelf device like hololens or
magic leap or something like that we
even though it cost way more than you
think it's gonna cost from the future
you know this is kind of a trick like
over spend in the early days like spend
more money than you have in order to get
that first test done if it's possible if
you don't have any money then you can't
but if you have a little bit of money
like spend that $400 to get like a
oculus so that you can simulate the
experience in in VR before you actually
go and make the hardware
from your own revenues and profits and
potentially giving so you yeah so I
think I mean I would actually go one
step above that and understand why
hardware companies need financing
usually it's for inventory it's rare
that a company will need to get funding
for it's not rare there's like funding
for inventory and there's funding for
R&D funding for R&D is like nxu like you
need you need that you can either get it
through free payments from potential
customers that's harder but most people
try to raise R&D funding from people at
YC or other investors banks will not
lend you money for R&D your family might
so I would like try to reduce that as
much as possible try to spend as little
money as possible hacking together
prototyping getting to the point where
you know what customer at products
you're going to build then on the
inventory financing side here's the
thing that I've learned inventory sucks
inventory is like one of the hardest
things that our companies have to deal
with because they can't make money
generally until they have a product that
they need to sell it cost money to build
that product and it costs time to build
that product so you have what's called a
cash conversion cycle where you may need
to put inputs dollars into your product
in order to get outputs down the road
again it is impossible it is very
difficult to manage inventory so the
better thing is actually to rise above
it and to get into a situation where you
don't need to buy as much inventory so
there's two ways that you can do this
one is you can get customers to
pre-order that's the easiest way is then
you have a very perfect idea of how many
units you need to build so that you can
and you can use that money from
pre-orders to actually fund the
development you don't need to raise
money from VCS you don't need to raise
money from banks that doesn't work
always but it does work in some crazy
situations like Xiaomi up until two or
three years ago sold their phones on
Tuesday mornings like they had a once
that you couldn't go on the website and
buy xiaomi phones you could only buy
them like Tuesday mornings and so it was
like the thing everyone who would be at
their computers on Tuesday mornings
waiting for like the latest drop Xiaomi
phones
and they had a really short production
cycle not a week but they knew basically
based on these prediction based on these
Tuesday sales how many units they need
to make over the next couple weeks
oneplus also did the same thing so
that's one way of doing it the pre-order
route the other way is to change your
product so that it takes a shorter
amount of time to build this is called
reducing the lead times so the benefit
the secret benefit of reducing your lead
times is that you have to put less of
your hard earned cash into inventory
that will then take months to turn into
actual revenue so interestingly enough
sometimes it's in your best interest to
pay more for the product pay more for
the bomb but Bill of Materials pay more
for the components if the lead times are
shorter because you may not actually
have a margin problem maybe like you
actually have quite a bit of margin free
margin but you have this cash flow
problem where you can't like fund new
batches of products because it takes six
months to turn that product into revenue
so you could take some of the margin you
could do a trade-off where you earn less
profit per unit but you're taking less
of a risk upfront that's kind of the
general learnings that I've had around
how didyou Hardware financing great
thank you very much Eric thank you
[Applause]
you